بينما تستند الكثير من النساء في عالم
المال والشهره الى ازواجهن او ابائهن فان
هذه المراه تسند اسره باكملها بعد انقادت
والدها وزوجها وشقيقها الى نادي المليارات
وهي السيده الاعلى اجرا في التاريخ
البريطانيه انها دينيس كود مؤسسه بيت 3 6
5 دوت كوم العملاق للمغامره عبر الانترنت
عام
وعاشت طفولتها في كنف والدها بتركوس الذي
كان ملهمها الاول فهو بحد ذاته قصه نجاح
حيث بدا حياته المهنيه وهو في الرابعه
عشره من عمره من عاملا بمنجما ثم بسلسله
مطاعم معروفه ترقى فيها واصبح المدير
اقليميا ليبدا حياه اكثر رفاهيه كان بيتر
مولعا بكره القدم حيث ما راسها كهيوايه
خلال نادي ستوك سيتي لكره القدم وهو ما
جعله يتجه لانشاء شركه لخدمات التموين
للاحداث الرياضيه قام بعدها بشراء سلسله
متاجر للمراهنات الرياضيه سماها لاحقا
بروفين قبل ان يصبح بحلول عام
1989 المساهمه الاكبر في ناديه السابق
ستوك سيتي دينيسيا لابنه الكبرى التي
تبناها وظيفيا بعد ان حصلت على شهاده في
الاقتصاد فعملت في قسم المحاسبه بشركه
بروفيشنا قبل ان تجد شغفها الحقيقيه
بالانتقال لوظيفه تشغيل السباقات
الاقليميه وهو ما كان بمثابه تحدي كبير في
مسيرتها لان السلسله كانت تمر بظروفها
صعبه
قبلت دنيسه التحدي وترقد في الوظيفه لمنصب
المدير العام سنه
1995 حيث عملت على شراء المزيد من صالات
الرهان لكن ذلك لم يكن كافيا لكسب
المنافسه بسوق المقامره ففكرت في الانتقال
لمساحه اكبر هي عالم الانترنت واقنعت
شقيقه جون لخوض المغامره معها فحصلت على
قرضا بضمان متاجر مراهنات العائله ثم
اطلقت في بدايه الالفيه موقع المقامره
الاكبر بيت 3 6 5 دوت كوم
قضت السيده الطموحه ساعات لا حصل لها في
العمل في الموقع من مبنى مؤقتا تم تثبيته
في موقف للسيارات بجوار احد متاجر
المراهنات التقليديه وبدلا من مجرد تقديم
المراهنات الرياضيه عبر الانترنت
العاب البينج والكازين والبوكر وسباق
الخيل وغير ذلك الكثير
على الموقع وجهه واحده للمقامره بحلول عام
2005 باعت دنيس عددا من المتاجر لشركه
كورال لكنها حافظت على نسبه المساهمه
الاكبر بالاضافه الى منصب الرئيس التنفيذي
جنبا الى جنب مع شقيقها جون حققت الشريكه
في عام 2013 ارباحا تزيد على 187 مليون
دولار لتدخل هي ووالدها ناديه اصحاب
المليارات وتصبح واحده من اقوى 100 امراه
في المملكه المتحده بعد عقدين من التاسيس
اكتسبت شركه بتري 6 5 اكثر من سته ملايين
عميل في 200 دوله واصبح لديها اكثر من
خمسه الاف موظف كما اصبح دخل دينيس موضوع
عن النقاش على مدار السنوات العديده
الماضيه فارباحها تجاوز 317 مليون دولار
في عام 20022 اعتبرت واحده من المديرين
التنفيذيين الاعلى اجرا في العالم باجمالي
رواتب يقدر بنحو 300 و 21 مليون دولار على
الاقل فيما تقدر ثروتها بخمسه مليارات
و300 مليون دولار ليس هذا فقط استطاع
الدينيس ان تحقق شغف والدها في كره القدم
مره اخرى وشراء نادي ستوك سيتي وغطى
الديون النادي الذي اصبح والدها رئيسا
الله فيما يديره زوجها ويشاركها شقيقها
اداره الاعمال
[موسيقى]